it's me your Jewish friend Sarah
Silverman do you hug
how are you doing sir I'm really excited
to try the most expensivest weed now
tell me about a little bit what you like
I heard you say sativa I do enjoy sativa
if I play basketball oh you who yeah you
play basketball I still play absolutely
I shot some jump shots today when I
smoke sativa
I get either incredibly in the zone
where I just am like my feet are my mind
it's all one piece or I'm terrible but
it's worth it because either way I'm
high
thank you thank you for sharing it Sarah
is that you don't like to be touched
well my face is just one of the most
precious things I'm sorry but it was
like a Jewish I couldn't control it I
had to
I mean I know I'm handsome I'm a
handsome I'm gonna have some black dude
I'm am I tall I knew I was gonna have
this effect on you especially my hair
was down I was like she's doing she's
gonna really later on in the episode me
and you will be pulling up on Kyle
cushion Kyle Cushman has came up with
some I have never heard of in my
life are you ready
vegan
and organic
[Music]
weed what meat is in weed it's like oh
is it like the cow manure that they the
soil or something I'm not I'm really not
sure I'm curious about that
marijuana has become a 10.8 billion
dollar market in the US the wheat
industry is growing rapidly and no one
knows growing weed better than former
High Times writer Kyle Cushman
chains and Sarah had to meet Kyle
because he's come up with the newest and
most expensivest cannabis yet you guys
ready to smoke some veganic cannabis cow
is here because he came up with his own
word y'all we've never heard this word
before the word is veganic Right organic
you can be organic
and then you can be veganic
and we're talking about weed we're
talking about a method of cultivation
you're going to be buying veganic
produce before too long for the consumer
do I lose weight if I you know smoke a
veganic joint do I not have preservative
is it all rain water what is it as the
Earth gets dirtier
the stuff coming out of the back ends of
the animals isn't as clean as it used to
be either
[Music]
that's where all of the heavy metal
accumulates but when you put that into
something that you're combusting and
that you're inhaling it's a lot
different than something that you can
wash off or that goes in through your
stomach you don't poop it out
I can't believe you're telling me my
timing is off I'm literally a comedian I
know it but I don't know because I don't
do stand up right I do TV really well
and I think if you just
wait one second before you say the next
thing and then say it dramatic pause
it'll hit we'll put a beating in post
crazy before we get into this is it
expensive it's really expensive to grow
veganically you have to spend 10 20
times the amount and what you feed the
plants really yeah the average cannabis
brand spends between twenty to fifty
dollars a pound on the food the
nutrients 20 or 50 a pound right to
produce a pound of weed to produce a
pound of weed right A veganic gardener
spends two hundred dollars a pound on
the food to feed their weed and you get
fed back
oh that's exciting cannabis is a bio
accumulator so anything that you feed it
inputs determine outputs it's just like
your body if you smoke veganic cannabis
all the time
you will feel better over all well
that's like when you say or
so clean I could go to church in it
I just remembered that that's a good one
because I was thinking like how can you
go to church in a vagina just because
it's clean
it just helps anyway I think the
question is like what do you use for
fertilizer so actually I make my own
line of vegan organic fertilizers called
vegan Matrix and made out of perfect
duties it's made out of protein and soy
hydrolates all the stuff that they would
till back into the soil after they grow
soybeans or things like that you take
the stalks and you take all the
leftovers and you ferment it you get the
nutrition out of it and you'll see the
first time you smoke it you'll notice
how clean it is
so what I brought here wow help yourself
what is this what kind is this this I
grew with my very own hands in my very
own house what's this oh I'm sorry
that's Oreos and then this one is filled
with half moon gelato this is an Indica
dominant hybrid and this is a sativa
dominant in here we've got a brand
called Zushi like sushi like sushi is it
raw let me see
oh I think I was smelling your hands
awesome JLo I've always wanted to smell
Jayla
I've already committed it to memory
that's JLo smell it
I'm here when it comes to mind you smell
that yellow
[Music]
God you hate me but you love me can we
get high but I got here for everybody is
some individual joints y'all can uh got
the gas
I'll grab one too all right and the
gloves I mean it's giving it's giving
like it's some good reasons
take that
this is the Oreo right the Oreo and so
this is a combination of Indica hybrid
if I'm correct because I have a really
good memory as an artist and a rapper
and
um
we we
oh my God it's a very clean nobody's
coughing yeah I might have a problem
with that I like feel my abs I'm not
smoking take a big hit then take a nice
big couple draws and make it good let's
let's see what it feels like
you still ain't gonna come
on there she goes
foreign
father the grandfather of the veganic
cultivation movement
this weed has a soul this weed has a
soul have you ever heard some sugar I
don't know say what you're gonna say
it's a great time absolutely you have
nothing to say
so they only spending twenty dollars on
the food to make the pound y'all again
my man right here spend a whole 200 250.
how much would this drink be how much
would how much a pound of uh Oreo going
for I need to get my bag of Oreo organic
cannabis if you can find it it's really
rare because of the work that goes into
it and the expense it's pretty damn near
a thousand dollars an ounce
what
yeah man look at man hell now
hell no a thousand dollars for a zip a
thousand dollars for 28 grams one
thousand dollars for
ounce of reef began son that
sometimes when you make it that
expensive it make people want it you
know what I'm saying all right good God
Almighty we got 16
000 for a pound
let's make it though
I didn't leave my house for five years
people just bring me money you need to
have for five years people just bring me
money why
boy I didn't man that's trapping man let
me get back to talking like the host of
a show and get rid of some of the slang
that comes with being a professional X
Trapper but like what is a host of a
show you are a host of a show you write
the book you're perfect
the way you are there is there's no one
in the world who can be you but you
what up what up what's up what's up man
God has blessed me with so much
tremendous ability to bury over the top
and I'm your host
every way you should play a partner
chicken
Two Chains 2 Chainz
blue
blue look at that oh Two Chains he gave
me everything thank you for giving me
the confidence I need to get through
get to the next level
go ahead there she go get out of there
you go
foreign
[Music]